[Music]  lady gaga  plays barista for the day  mother monster's suited up in her very  own green apron  and post it up behind the counter of a  Los Angeles Starbucks on Friday serving  coffee to surprised customers is part of  her cups of kindness collaboration with  the company and our customer name  whether she was ringing people up or  brewing up a beverage  it seems Gaga kept her cool no matter  what the task the singer teamed up with  the Seattle based brew house to create  four new drinks you can find them at  participating locations through June 19  25 cents from each beverage purchase  will be donated to Gaga's Born This Way  Foundation  [Music]  you